[ SPEAKING KOREAN ]
>> TRANSLATOR: WHAT IS
DIRECTING?
WHAT DOES IT REALLY MEAN
TO BE A DIRECTOR?
I'M A DIRECTOR MYSELF,
BUT I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO SAY WHEN I
GET ASKED THIS QUESTION.
IT'S A LITTLE EMBARRASSING
TO ANSWER WITH A STRAIGHT FACE.
A BIT CRINGY AS WELL.
BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE, IT'S DIFFICULT TO GIVE
A SHORT AND CLEAR
ANSWER.
[ SPEAKING KOREAN ]
>> TRANSLATOR: WHEN I
GET ASKED THIS QUESTION
DURING AN INTERVIEW,
I JUST WANT TO GLOSS
OVER THE ANSWER
OR RUN AWAY.
BUT THIS TIME, I WAS THE
ONE TO ASK THIS
QUESTION TO THE FIVE DIRECTORS
NOMINATED TONIGHT.
[ SPEAKING KOREAN ]
>> TRANSLATOR: THE
QUESTION WAS,
IF YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO A
RANDOM KID ON THE STREET WHAT
DIRECTING IS IN 20 SECONDS,
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
[ SPEAKING KOREAN ]
>> TRANSLATOR: THE FIVE
DIRECTORS ALL SENT THEIR REPLIES.
THE REPLIES WERE SOMETHING
VERY PERSONAL.
[ SPEAKING KOREAN ]
>> AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
CHLOE ZHAO, "NOMADLAND."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
OH, MAN.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU
TO THE ACADEMY.
THANK YOU TO MY BRILLIANT,
BRILLIANT NOMINEES,
FELLOW NOMINEES,
THANK YOU.
MY ENTIRE "NOMADLAND"
COMPANY.
WHAT A CRAZY ONCE IN A LIFETIME
JOURNEY WE WENT ON TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO YOU.
I'VE BEEN THINKING A LOT
LATELY OF HOW I KEEP GOING WHEN
THINGS GET HARD.
AND I THINK IT GOES BACK TO
SOMETHING I LEARNED
WHEN I WAS A KID.
WHEN I WAS GROWING UP IN CHINA,
MY DAD AND I USED TO PLAY THIS GAME.
WE WOULD MEMORIZE CLASSIC
CHINESE POEMS AND TEXTS,
AND WE WOULD RECITE
IT TOGETHER AND TRY TO
FINISH EACH OTHER'S
SENTENCES.
AND THERE WAS ONE THAT
I REMEMBER SO DEARLY
IT'S CALLED "THE THREE
CHARACTER CLASSICS."
AND THE FIRST PHRASE GOES --
[ SPEAKING CHINESE ]
PEOPLE AT BIRTH ARE
INHERENTLY GOOD.
AND THOSE SIX LETTERS HAD SUCH A
GREAT IMPACT ON ME WHEN I WAS A KID.
AND I STILL TRULY BELIEVE
THEM TODAY.
EVEN THOUGH SOMETIMES IT MAY
SEEM LIKE THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
BUT I HAVE ALWAYS FOUND GOODNESS
IN THE PEOPLE I MET.
EVERYWHERE I WENT IN THE WORLD.
SO THIS IS FOR ANYONE WHO HAS
THE FAITH AND THE COURAGE TO
HOLD ON TO THE GOODNESS IN THEMSELVES.
AND TO HOLD ON TO THE GOODNESS
IN EACH OTHER.
NO MATTER HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS TO DO THAT.
AND THIS IS FOR YOU, YOU INSPIRE
ME TO KEEP GOING.
THANK YOU.